JORDAN THIBODEAU: So we're
going talk to Matt and Amanda
about the book.
And then we're going to work
in some of your questions.
So my first question
was, what inspired
you to write this book?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: Well,
I think it was really,
I've been in the industry
for 18 years now.
She's been in it about 16.
And so over the
years you obviously
hear a lot of stories.
You experience a lot of
things with different clients.
But 95% of our clients are
in the real estate industry.
And so it was kind of a--
when you hear the recurring
stories, the recurring
mistakes, the lessons
that people need to learn, it
just seemed like a great avenue
to put them together and do
it in a way that it was fun.
Obviously taxes aren't
the most exciting topic,
and I congratulate you all
for sitting here after lunch,
listening to a tax talk.
So good for that.
But I think it was a good way
for us to do it in a fun way,
teach people some lessons that
can reach a lot of people, not
just our clientele, per se.
But I think that was one of the
motivating reasons for doing
it.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: One question
Googlers ask me is what can you
and what can't
you deduct things?
And so people say, can
I write off my kids
for my real estate business?
Not can I write my kids
off emotionally, but more
on the real estate
side of things?
[LAUGHS]
So maybe you can go over
some of the common deductions
that real estate investors miss.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah, I think one
of the main things to understand
is that anything potentially
could be tax deductible.
So the question you ask yourself
is if you're spending money
on something, is it
ordinary and necessary
for my real estate business?
So some of the most
commonly missed
ones would be like car expenses,
travel costs, cellphones,
computers.
These are things that we all
use on a day-to-day basis
personally, but we also use it
to help us in our real estate.
So there's a common
myth out there
that we can't deduct
any of these things
unless we have a legal entity.
So that's a question
we get all the time.
Do I have to have an LLC
to deduct certain things?
Fortunately, the answer is no.
The IRS doesn't really care
whether you have an entity
or not.
What they care about is
whether you have a business.
And business really
just means do I
have an intent to make profit?
In our example, it's the
real estate business.
So that's probably,
like you said,
the most common question--
what can I deduct?
It's hard to say.
What you can't deduct
would be things
that are more not necessary
for your real estate business.
So as an example for
a lot of our clients,
we have a list of
100 tax deductions.
It's a little checklist.
Of course, that's not going
to apply to everybody.
Not all 100 items will be
applicable to your real estate
business.
But the key is to learn to
think about it from a more
creative perspective.
And I know all Googlers are
very creative in nature.
So the question to ask yourself
when you're spending money
on something is how can I make
this ordinary and necessary
for my particular
real estate business?
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Excellent.
Now, for people who don't have
an investment property, yet
they're going out to
scout for property,
can we write those expenses off?
And do we have to write
them off the same year we
find the property?
Or is there a way to hold onto
those for a couple years or so?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: It's
a good question, and one
that we do get a lot.
So if you are looking
for your first property,
you are going to incur
expenses to do that.
You're going to incur travel.
Maybe you're putting some
expenses down for property,
to do an inspection
or appraisal, whatever
it might be.
If it's your first property
that you're buying,
all those
preaquisition costs are
going to get lumped together.
It's generally what's considered
startup costs of your business.
And startup costs, you
can write off up to $5,000
right away, once you
"start" business.
So with an investment
property, easiest way
to think about it when
you start business
is when you actually close on
the purchase of the property.
So at that point
in time, if you've
incurred less than $5,000,
you can write them off all
right away.
If you've incurred
more than $5,000,
you take 5,000 right away.
And the rest you can
write off over 15 years.
15 years is a long
time, obviously.
Not a great answer,
and most people
want to write things
off right away.
But that's kind of the way
that the tax law looks at it.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah,
and I think something
to add-- if you think about it,
what the IRS is really doing
is they're incentivizing
us to pull the trigger,
and invest sooner
rather than later.
Right?
So they're rewarding you.
If you're spending money to
learn how to do real estate,
you're traveling to
look at real estate,
really the deduction comes
in once you start investing.
So the earlier you
start investing,
the better the tax deduction.
On the other hand,
if you're someone
who's been taking classes, it's
been years and years and years
and still haven't really
pulled the trigger yet,
those items still could
be tax deductible.
But it's just going to be
delayed into the future when
you actually pull the trigger.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Gotcha.
One thing I struggle with is
when I go on scouting trips.
I have all of these receipts and
it's just very time consuming,
writing all these receipts
down and putting them
in the right Excel spreadsheets.
How do you guys manage that?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: A lot of
our clients use Quickbooks.
It's very popular
accounting software.
We like to say,
it's good and bad.
It's good because
it's very easy to use.
And it's bad for us, because
it's very easy for you guys
to use it, depending on how
well a person utilizes it.
But it can make things easier.
One of the things that
we learned from a mentor
early on was to
hire an assistant.
You know, and it might seem
kind of like a crazy idea
for you, if you're just
starting investing.
But it can be a virtual
assistant, someone like that.
AMANDA HAN: Or it
could be your kid,
like what Jordan said earlier.
If you want to hire your kids
to help with your real estate
business, what a great
person to help you
scan receipts and do data entry.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: And
that's a good point.
The IRS, they don't
need to see paper.
So you can scan a receipt
and toss the receipt.
So scanning and organizing,
however it makes sense for you,
whether it's file
holders or on the cloud
or whatever it is, just find
something that works for you.
But you just need to be able
to find the receipt if you ever
need it.
So I think that's some
big good tips that we've
talked to our clients about.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Excellent.
Now, you guys are
practicing CPAs.
So I was lucky to
come across you guys
through bigger pockets.
But then I get asked
through the Google alias,
how do I go about
finding a good CPA?
How do I judge if the CPA
can work with real estate
investors?
Do you have any
tips you can share,
help us identify good CPAs?
AMANDA HAN: I think
your local community.
So if you're an
investor, you're probably
networking with other investors.
So it's a good idea to ask
who other people are using?
What's been their experience
in working with CPAs?
In the interview, ask them
questions about real estate.
What are you seeing
with your other clients?
What are your other clients
doing in real estate?
Do they have issues
with obtaining financing
or obtaining deals?
So that will help you
gauge you know how involved
they are in real estate.
I know a lot of real
estate investors
are very creative, so doing
a lot of creative deals
with a lot of
creative terminology.
So you just want
to make sure you
work with someone who
understands the terminology
you're talking about.
So if you're doing
a lease option,
and you're talking to them and
you get really glazed look,
that's probably a
sign that you're not
talking to the right person.
Because they're supposed
to be your adviser.
So just things like
that, talking to them,
getting to know how
much they really
understand your industry.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: And I think
just like doctors or attorneys,
not all accountants
are great and equal
or do the exact same thing.
So just because
someone's a CPA and does
taxes doesn't mean they do
taxes for real estate investors.
So obviously that can
be question number one,
and then dig into other
further questions.
Because we see that
time and time again,
where people have
hired somebody who
just doesn't have experience
with real estate, and things
are missed.
And sometimes you can fix it.
Sometimes you can't.
So it can create
issues down the road.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah, and
believe it or not,
we actually have a
handful of clients
who are CPAs themselves.
They do taxes, maybe for
manufacturing or R&D stuff.
And then they have
us do consulting,
or we actually do the
tax returns for all
their real estate things.
So it's perfectly
fine if you have
lots of different
things going on, just
to make sure you're speaking
with the right person.
The thing that is the funniest
to me, I hear all the time,
is people will call me and
say, oh, you know, I heard
about this particular strategy.
And I say, where did
you hear that from?
And they'll say, oh, I
heard it from my realtor.
So that's not what
you want to do.
You don't want to be taking
tax advice from your realtor
or your dentist.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: What
are some common mistakes
that CPAs make in
the tax field when
they're working our returns?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: I think
with respect to real estate,
believe it or not, one of the
biggest ones that we see missed
is depreciation.
So for those of you who may be
new to real estate investing,
depreciation is you buy a
property, just like a stock.
You don't necessarily get to
deduct the property right away.
You've got to write
it off over time.
And you do that
through depreciation.
So it's kind of a paper expense.
You get a certain
amount every year.
Now, for us, who does real
estate tax stuff all the time,
it's kind of like
real estate 101.
But 10%, 15% of
the time we see it
either done wrong, or believe
it or not, totally just not
taken at all.
We had a client a couple
years back that had,
I don't know, a
dozen properties.
She'd owned them for
10, 12, 15 years.
And you look at her return,
she hadn't taken depreciation
on any of them over the years.
So the benefit of
the depreciation
is that it's an
expense you can deduct
against your other income
from the rental properties.
So maybe you had
cash flow positive.
But with the depreciation,
you're at zero.
Or maybe you're even a loss
on your rental property
for tax purposes, which
could be a good thing.
And this person has missed
out for 10 or 12 years.
So luckily there was a
way we could help her.
But it was just mind blowing
when you look at it, that you
haven't been doing this.
You're a real estate investor
and working with somebody,
haven't done this for so long.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah, I think
another thing-- maybe
not a mistake per se-- but
I think a lot of accountants
or most accountants are
not creative by nature.
So we're more critical thinking.
And so I think a
really good practice
to get into-- when you
meet with your tax advisor,
instead of asking them-- like
you were saying earlier-- can I
write off my kids?
Can I write off my kids?
Can I write of this
particular purchase?
Maybe the immediate answer
is no, you can't do it.
But instead,
rephrase the question
to ask, how can I
write off my kids?
How can I do it?
Well, maybe you can have your
kids help in your real estate
business.
How can I write off
my trip to Florida?
Well maybe you can have
some pre-determined business
meetings, schedule things with
local real estate investors
or potential lenders
working in your deals.
So just adding that one
simple word, I think really
helps a lot when you're
meeting with your tax advisor,
to put them in that
more creative thinking.
And it's funny because I tell
people this all the time,
and it's interesting.
Because sometimes I have clients
that throw this back to me.
I was talking to
someone the other day
because they had a
big legal expense.
This is personal stuff.
Can I deduct it?
And I said, no.
And he's like,
well, the question
is how can I deduct it?
So then it was a completely
different conversation.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Right.
So you had a story in
your book about Jeff,
about him creating the entities.
Can you talk about
that story and then
go into common pitfalls
people find themselves
in regarding setting up entities
in real estate investing?
AMANDA HAN: Sure.
I'll let you do that then.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
Well, let's say,
Jeff is somebody, kind
of a newbie investor.
And I'm trying to
recall the facts to a T.
But I think he lost
his job, right?
And he was getting
into real estate
and going to different
seminars, educating himself,
which is important.
It's a good practice to be in.
But he got to the point where
he was going to these things
and he was forking
over thousands
of dollars on education and/or
creating legal entities.
One of those-- I don't
know if you guys have
been to educational events
like that, where it's
the run to the back of the
room for the next five minutes,
and you get this great deal.
And you can create 10 entities.
And you know, circle the
wagons or whatever it is.
So he did something like that,
where at the end of the day,
he was in $10,000?
He was $10,000 in with
four new entities.
And when you look back, he
didn't have a single property
yet.
AMANDA HAN: So one
of the issues that he
asked is what is our fee
for doing tax returns?
Because we met him at a
local real estate club.
And so I was really
excited when he
was telling me about all
these different entities.
I was like, well,
how many properties?
What are we talking about?
And that's when we learned he
didn't have any properties.
And so that's the part
that's very alarming.
And I think just touching on
a common mistake for people
starting out-- you do
want to have your entities
and your strategies in place.
But you don't
necessarily always need
to be pulling the trigger
on entity formation, per se.
So as an example, if you
have no properties yet,
keep track of your expenses.
They will become tax
deductible when you do
start investing in real estate.
But what we don't
want you to do is
go out and spend a lot of
money on attorneys and CPAs
and form all these
entities if you're really
not going to be able to buy
property maybe until next year.
Right?
Because California,
not only do we
have to pay the attorney
to form the entity.
The state also charges
us at least $800
per year, per
entity, just in fees.
So before you start
making any money,
we just want to make
sure that the cost is
justified by the profit that
you're going to be making.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: Well, and
think about it for Jeff too.
He was $10,000 in that
he had already spent.
And that, I think he had
even borrowed most of that,
if I remember.
And he had no other money.
That could've been
$10,000 as a down payment
on a potential
investment property.
Obviously out of state,
probably, somewhere.
So that's the thing
you got to look at,
is weighing what do
you have to spend
and not doing-- what is
it-- paralysis by analysis
or analysis paralysis, where
we've seen that, where people,
they feel like I need
to know this much
or whatever that
much is, they feel
like they need to get there.
When in reality,
take small steps.
Pull the trigger.
Learn your lessons.
You can always create an
entity after the fact.
If you need it for
asset protection
to title the property
into the entity.
That's doable.
It doesn't need to
be done upfront.
So there's ways to make it work
without spending a boatload.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Right.
So I hear people
talking about setting up
LLCs for tax benefits.
Are there additional tax
benefits you gain with an LLC?
AMANDA HAN: Well, it depends.
It depends on what you're
doing in real estate.
Because real estate's
a general term, right?
So you could be doing
rental real estate.
You could be doing
property management.
wholesale and fix and flip.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Let's say buy
and hold, because most of us
do that.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah,
for buy and hold,
there is not an
added tax benefit.
So what that means is if you
buy a rental property down
the street, you will
get the same write off
and deductions as if
you own the property
in your individual name.
So earlier we were talking
about maybe shifting income
to your kids, pay them to
help with your receipts
and bookkeeping on the rentals.
You can do that
with an LLC, or you
can do that if you own the
property in your personal name.
Same with travel expenses.
If you're deducting
a home office,
all those are the same
with or without an LLC.
Now, if you're someone
who's more involved
in active real estate-- and
some common examples of that
would be wholesaling, flipping,
you're doing syndications,
maybe you're a realtor,
also, on the side
and you're making
commissions income.
In those examples
there are tax benefits
of being inside
of a legal entity.
Because that type of
income is taxed differently
than rental real estate.
But for rental real
estate purposes,
there's not really
an added benefit.
In fact, there's a cost that we
just talked about, right? $800,
at least, to the state
every single year.
But we do have a lot
of clients who have
LLCs for rental real estate.
Mostly it's for asset
protection purposes.
So if you're someone
who has a lot of equity
in the real estate, or if
you have a lot of net worth,
it could make sense to have an
LLC, just for asset protection
reasons.
OK?
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Now,
Are there other ways
to get asset protection
outside the LLCs,
like umbrella insurance
or anything else?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: Yeah,
it's a great question.
There's other ways, for sure.
And we talk to our
clients about it.
One is legal entities.
That's one option.
You mentioned
umbrella insurance.
That's a good option as well.
One of the tips we like to
mention with umbrella insurance
is just to make sure that the
activity that you are hoping
it's going to cover, that
actually the insurance
covers that activity.
Because we've talked to even
our own insurance agent,
like for one of our
rental properties.
And we want to make sure the
investment covers investment
properties.
Yes, it does.
OK, well, send us the policy.
We flip to the Exclusions page.
And lo and behold,
bullet point number five
says it excludes
investment properties.
So he obviously didn't know
what he was talking about.
So I mention that because
I've heard that from clients
as well, is that sometimes
they look at their exclusions
and it specifically
mentions it's not included.
So if you're going to get
umbrella, make sure it covers.
If it doesn't, make
sure it has a rider that
covers investment properties.
AMANDA HAN: Also
debt-- you know,
debt is a really good
asset protection tool.
So if you have a property
where it's mostly debt,
odds of someone suing
and getting access
to that small amount of equity
is probably not as traumatizing
as if you had a property where
you might have paid all cash
or you have a couple thousand
dollars worth of equities
sitting in there.
That might keep you up at night.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Gotcha.
I have a specific
question for a Googler.
"When would an S Corp. Make
more sense than the LLC?"
The person owns two
investment houses
and would like to buy more.
"The growing question
for my husband
and I is, should we own these
individually, or have them
in some sort of
business corporation?
What is the best
way to structure
owning multiple properties
to optimize taxes paid
and protect ourself?"
AMANDA HAN: So that's
a really good question,
going back to what we
were just talking about.
For rental real estate,
whether you own one
or whether you own 100, there's
really not a tax difference
whether you own it
personally or in your LLC.
Now, for that particular
person, the question
about as the S Corporation,
that's a really good question.
So generally, we
recommend S Corporations
for active real estate
income, so wholesale,
fix and flip, real
estate commissions.
One little tip that we
tell a lot of our clients
is if you're someone who's
doing active real estate,
it might make sense
to form an LLC.
That LLC, we can
always choose later
on how it wants to pay taxes.
Meaning a year from now, we can
look back and say, well, how
did your active real estate do?
What was the profit?
Was it $10,000?
Was it $100,000?
And from there, we
can retroactively
file changes with
the IRS to say, OK,
now I want this LLC to be
taxed as an S Corp or a C Corp,
or even just as a disregarded
entity, being an LLC itself.
On the active income side, if
you're a real estate investor
making active income, the S Corp
does save you roughly 7% to 15%
in taxes, on average, as opposed
to earning that type of money
in your individual name.
So that's where the
tax savings comes from.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: Another
tip with the S Corp,
going back to the
investment property,
we generally do not
recommend having
S Corporations own rental
properties, long-term hold
investment properties.
The reason being is
that down the road
it can create adverse
tax consequences.
So let's say, the S
Corp owns a property.
Maybe it's got debt on it.
Maybe it doesn't.
But you're trying
to refinance it.
Sometimes the banks are
going to want the property
to be owned in your title
deed or personal name
for whatever reason.
Because maybe you have to
get the loan, or something
like that.
Well, if you have to transfer
title from the S Corp
to the personal
in that situation,
that creates phantom
income for you,
as if you sold the property.
And so that's why
we generally don't
recommend using a
C Corp or even an S
Corp to own rental properties.
That's where owning
in your personal name
or looking at LLCs
for asset protection
would be probably the way to go.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Makes sense.
Another question
from a Googler--
"If I purchase a buy-and-hold
property under my own name
then later decide to
create an LLC, how tricky
is it to transfer the
existing property into the LLC
without paying gains?
I've heard that this
being done, but I've also
read that it can be a pain."
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
How tricky is it?
It's not "tricky."
But it can be done without
any tax consequences.
So you can own a property
in your personal name,
decide six months
later to create an LLC
and want to hold title
for protection purposes.
You can transfer
title using a deed.
It should be as simple as that.
You have to look
at your insurance.
Make sure that you're adding
the LLC as an additional insured
on your insurance policy.
If you have debt
on the property,
technically that's going to
trigger to due-on-sale clause.
So a lot of our
clients just leave
the debt in their
personal name, transfer
title, keep paying the debt,
and that's not an issue.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
Can you explain
what the due-on-sale clause is?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
Yeah, due-on-sale just
means on a mortgage-- there's a
clause in everybody's mortgage
that says, if you
try to transfer
title of this property,
we, as the lender,
have the right to
call the note due,
meaning you have to pay us back.
Now, I've never heard of a
bank actually doing that.
But technically speaking,
if you transferred title,
they could do it.
But again, most
banks, they'll do it,
especially if you continue to
pay the mortgage, obviously.
So now, you can go
to them and ask them.
Most banks will probably say no.
Like I said, most clients
just transfer title
and leave the debt where it
is and just deal with it.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Going
back to tax strategy,
can you explain what
a 1031 exchange is?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: Yeah,
so a 1031 exchange, it's
simple as think about
it back to Monopoly.
You've got the green house.
You want to buy the
red hotel, or you
want to sell the green house
and buy two green houses.
And you want to do it in
a tax-efficient manner.
So maybe that first
green house, you've
built up a lot of
equity and gain.
If you sell it, you're going to
have a big gain and a big tax
bill.
Well, the IRS has
this code-- 1031--
that allows you to sell that
if you reinvest it and follow
the rules into new
investment properties,
you don't have to
pay the tax when
you sell the first property.
It basically defers
that tax until you
sell the new properties
down the road.
Like, theoretically,
you could continue.
You could sell one,
buy a replacement,
sell that one two
years later, and just
rolling this down the road.
And theoretically, not paying
taxes for 10, 20, 30, 40 years.
So it's a great
vehicle for investors
to keep that extra
chunk of cash that you
might lose to taxes if you
were to sell your property.
Because think about it.
If your tax bill was
going to be $50,000,
I mean, that $50,000 is a down
payment on another investment
property.
So if you can save that now,
buy another property that's
going to appreciate,
generate cash flow for you,
you're taking away
that tax drag that's
going to slow you down
from building wealth.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah, this is a
really interesting time for you
to bring it up.
I just talked to a
new client yesterday.
The woman is 96 years old.
And she came in with her son.
They bought a property
in LA, back in the days,
for something like $20,000.
Now it's worth
over $2.2 million.
And so for them to sell it
outright, pay the capital
gain between Federal
and California,
in case you didn't
know, California
doesn't have capital gains.
So we're just paying
ordinary income tax
on the sale of real estate.
So close to a million dollars
would go away into taxes
if they were to sell this
property just without a 1031.
So one of the things
that we're working on
is for them to sell and to
buy a couple of replacement
properties, both in state.
And they're also looking
for out of state.
So essentially, that
allows them to lock
in the gain on this
highly-appreciated property
with zero taxes.
And because mom
is so old in age,
the ultimate strategy
would be for mom
to basically pass away with
these properties in her trust.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: You laugh,
but this is a real strategy.
I'm telling you.
[LAUGHS]
AMANDA HAN: Sorry, I don't
mean the ultimate strategy is
for her to pass away, period.
[LAUGHS]
After she passes
away, then the kids
inherit the real estate
from mom through the trust.
And what happens
is, at that time,
the kids can turn around
and sell those properties
the very next day if they
wanted to, for $2 million.
And they would get that
money completely tax free.
So 1031's a very, very
powerful strategy.
A lot of times for many people,
for many long-term investors,
it's kind of a let's
make sure we keep it
in the parents'
name, and then we
pass it to the kids
with zero taxes ever.
So the question is
she had $2 million,
what if the properties
were worth a lot more--
$5, $10 million?
That's a really great question.
Right now, the estate tax,
the first roughly $5 million
is tax free.
So for a husband and wife,
this strategy is s up to,
roughly, the first $10 million.
You don't have to worry
about estate taxes.
For those of you with parents
that have over $10 million
worth of estate
taxes, it's going
to be a combination strategy.
Part of that should probably
be gifted to the kids
now, so that we leave roughly
$10 million in parents' name.
It's really exciting
to do that kind
of multigenerational planning.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: So let's
say I had a personal residence
and I wanted to do
a 1031 exchange.
Could I sell that property
and push those funds
into an apartment complex?
Or does it have to be
a like kind property?
AMANDA HAN: So
really good question.
If you own a primary
home and it's
highly appreciated in this
area, after the gain exclusion,
you can only use a 1031
exchange if you turn that home
into a rental first.
So if I just have
a primary home,
it's always been a primary
home, I cannot 1031 exchange
into some other property.
I would have to pay
taxes on the gain.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
What's the difference
between retroactive tax strategy
and proactive tax strategy?
You brought that up
in the book, and that
was a really interesting topic.
AMANDA HAN: Well,
there's actually
no such thing as a
retroactive tax "strategy,"
because you can't
plan after the fact.
So really if you're meeting with
your CPA January through April,
there's really
not any strategies
going on at that time.
Really we're just looking
at OK, what did you do?
And what's the best
way we can present
what has already happened?
So in a 1031 exchange
scenario, for example,
if you sold the property and
then we see you next year,
well, we can't really do a 1031
because the year's gone by.
And in fact, the sale
transaction has been closed.
Proactive strategy
really is just
meeting with your tax
advisors throughout the year
before you make these
significant financial or
personal decisions-- a
decision to leave your job,
to start a new job, to move
your retirement money around,
buy, sell real
estate, obviously.
And so before you enter
into a transaction,
your advisor can
help you calculate
what is the tax impact?
And what are the options?
Proactive planning
really is just
another way to say, OK,
well here are your options.
You can either replace it and
save this amount of taxes.
Or you can sell the
property, take the cash,
and run with it
if you wanted to.
As long as you're willing to pay
the tax, maybe down the road.
And tax planning doesn't have
to be very in-depth or scary.
It doesn't have to be hours
and hours of sitting with a CPA
going over numbers.
We really encourage
our clients like hey,
if you're doing anything at
all, send us a quick e-mail.
You're moving, you're
thinking of changing jobs,
send us an e-mail.
And then from that, we can look
at your situation and say, OK,
does this warrant
a conversation?
Do we have follow up questions?
Are there things that
maybe we're concerned with?
Or maybe there's nothing
we're concerned with.
We say, OK, thanks
for the update.
I'll keep it in
the back of my mind
if something tax-law
wise comes up
that I think will
impact you, that's
when communication will be made.
But it doesn't have to
be a very formal process
where it's very time intensive.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Gotcha.
In the book, you have a section
about self-directed 401K.
It's a two-parter.
First, what is a
self-directed 401K?
And as far as employees
who are working,
who have benefits where they
get 401K contributions that
match, how can we take advantage
of a self-directed 401K?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
So kind of break up
the question a little bit.
So self-directed
retirement investing,
or self-directed
retirement plans,
the term, self-directed,
all that means
is that traditionally when you
go to open an IRA or a Roth IRA
at a custodian, Fidelity, pick
one, a Vanguard, whatever,
they're going to give
you some options of what
you can invest in, right?
Stocks, bonds, mutual funds.
Well, the term
self-directed really
means you're going to a specific
type of retirement custodian
that you choose what
you want to invest in.
So you can get your IRA
to invest in real estate.
you can get it to
invest in collectibles.
You can get it to invest
in almost anything.
A lot of people
don't know that they
can use their IRA to
invest in things outside
of the stock market.
But it has been allowed
for 40 years or something.
So we have a lot of clients
that do self-directed investing.
Now, they may be using
an individual retirement
account, a self-directed
IRA or a self-directed Roth.
Or they might have
their own business
where they've set up
a self-directed 401K.
Any One of those options, the
type of investing you can do
is basically all the same.
And so if somebody
is working at Google,
you have a retirement
account here.
But maybe you want
to start your own.
You have an IRA on the
side, but maybe you're
not happy with what
it's investing in,
and you know real estate.
Well, maybe you can just roll
that money from your existing
IRA, open up a self-directed
IRA to one of these custodians.
Roll your money over.
It's a tax-free rollover.
And then find your
investment vehicle
for that self-directed IRA,
and start investing in stuff
that you know more about, or
that you have, knowledge wise,
an advantage over them
in the stock market
or in the mutual funds
or something like that.
AMANDA HAN: I'm
curious-- have you
looked into the possibility
of rolling your Google 401K
money into a self-directed?
Have you asked that ever?
JORDAN THIBODEAU: I haven't
personally looked into that.
But it's a question
that's raised here.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah, that might
be something for you guys
collectively to talk
to Google about.
Because the IRS does
not really care who
your custodian is--
if it's with Google,
if it's with TD Ameritrade
or Morgan Stanley.
So the IRS is the
same as if it was
with a self-directed custodian.
So it's kind of like
Wells Fargo versus B of A.
It's all the same thing to them.
So as long as your employer
allows you to do that,
then it is possible to
roll your money-- the work
401K-- into a self-directed
IRA and be able to deploy
that for real estate.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: What's
the best income tax
strategy for high-earned
income employees here?
And to follow through,
would be a good idea
to buy an investment property
if it was losing money, just
for the tax benefits?
OK.
That's why the softball
was being thrown at you.
[LAUGHS]
I could see from the
reactions from your eyes,
it was like, no.
God, no.
AMANDA HAN: I think for
high-income individuals,
it is a good idea to invest in
profit-generating rental real
estate.
Because on other
types of investment
you are making-- let's
say, in the stock market,
or invest in another
startup company-- the income
that you get is probably
going to be taxed,
along with your W-2 income.
So that's going to be
at a high tax rate.
Versus rental real
estate, at a minimum,
it does give you a lot of tax
write offs-- a lot of the ones
we talked about
earlier-- in addition
to what Matt mentioned
about depreciation.
So it's not uncommon for us
to see high-income individuals
invest in real estate
with the result being
that at least the
rental income is coming
to them on a tax-free basis.
So that's the first
tier we want to get to,
is at least tax-free
rental income.
And that is available,
I would say,
to the majority of
real estate investors.
If you're working
with the right CPA,
there should be enough
deductions pulled out
so you can reach that level.
Then the next question
just becomes, OK,
if I do such a good job at
capturing my expenses that I
actually show a loss
on my tax return,
how can I use that to offset
the taxable income from my W-2,
for example?
And so one of the
great ways to do
that is if you-- or if you're
married, you have a spouse--
can qualify as a real
estate professional.
By being a real
estate professional,
all that means in a
tax world is that you
can use the rental losses to
now offset the taxable income
from your W-2 as well.
So instead of seeing
them separately,
it's now all rolled into one.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: So
a big picture-- maybe
you've got enough
rental properties
that, like we talked about,
are cash flow positive.
But we can generate enough
depreciation in the home office
deductions, hiring your kids,
other strategies to generate
that the expenses are
more than the income
so you have a loss now.
But really, you're still
cash-flow positive.
But now we're just utilizing
deductions for all the things
that you already are paying for.
And then you can use that to
offset the income taxes you're
paying on your W-2.
That's the ultimate goal.
And that's where if
you can get someone
in the family that can qualify
as a real estate professional,
that would allow you to do that.
Or go marry somebody that's
a real estate professional.
You know, marriage
counseling here, you know?
So that's one way.
I mean he talked about other
things for high-income earners.
One of the things we talk
to a lot of clients about,
because it's something
we're passionate about.
I know you said, you give
back a lot of your time.
You can incorporate
charitable giving
with real estate investing.
There's lots of different
strategies out there.
I mean, obviously you can give
straight cash to a charity.
You can give household
goods to charity.
You can do all that.
But there's more
advanced strategies,
where you can put
money in things
that are a charitable trust.
You can put money in.
You can get a donation deduction
for the money going in.
And then the trust actually goes
out and buys rental properties
and generates cash flow, and
then donates the cash flow
to charities.
And so it's a way for you
to still buy real estate,
build wealth.
But at the same time,
get tax deductions now,
if maybe you can't qualify as
a real estate professional,
let's say, you're still
offsetting the high W-2 income.
So there's definitely
ways to do it.
And sometimes it just
involves changing
the fact pattern a little bit.
People have to be willing to
change their fact pattern.
AMANDA HAN: I was going to say,
about the charitable planning
strategy, I mean, it's a
somewhat advanced strategy.
But one of the things that a
lot of people like about that
is at the end of the day,
you do own the asset again.
So you know, if what you donated
into the charitable trust
is three rental
properties, for example,
at the end of the trust term,
those three properties revert
back to your
ownership or your LLC,
or your estate,
however you dictate it.
And so that makes sense.
A lot of times,
if we have clients
who have an extraordinary year--
maybe stock options or payouts,
or something like that-- and
they want to buy real estate.
They don't necessarily need
the income from the real estate
just yet.
But they do want the asset.
They do want to own the
real estate in the future.
It's a really great way to get
a very large write off in a year
where you have a significant
increase of income.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
I had two questions.
One just under your
very first thing.
I have two rental properties,
and also an umbrella policy.
And what would we need
the umbrella policy for,
in terms of the rental property?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
So the question,
what do you need the
umbrella policy for,
for the rental properties?
It's more for the exposure.
And obviously we're
not attorneys.
We're not litigation attorneys.
But it's more of a if the
crap hits the fan, you know,
somebody trips and falls
on your property or--
AUDIENCE: On the
rental property?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: Yeah,
on your rental property--
falls off a railing or decides
to see you for some reason
and can make the argument,
in a court of law,
they should be
entitled to something.
That's where the umbrella
insurance, theoretically,
would kick in to
protect you, for having
to fork out $50,000 for
some plaintiff or something.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, actually, but
my most important question.
My kind of funny personal thing.
But my sister is breaking up
with her boyfriend in Atlanta.
And they own a condominium.
She owns 1/3.
He owns 2/3.
She doesn't have a lot of
money, a lot of income.
So I'm going to buy him out, his
2/3 property, his 2/3 portion.
How should I structure that,
in terms of my income tax?
Or how would a
person, anybody here,
buying a property
with a sibling,
how can you do that
so that you can maybe
treat that as
rental income and I
could get some
kind of deduction,
but she can continue
having partial ownership?
AMANDA HAN: Hmm.
That's a really good question.
So I'm assuming your sister
is going to still live there
as her primary home.
So generally, the way we set
up on the tax returns side,
is you would claim the
1/2 of it, or 2/3 of that,
as rental income,
rental expenses.
And then her
portion of that, she
would just claim as a
regular primary home.
So she would have a little
bit of mortgage interest
and property taxes.
Now, with respect to how
you hold title, again,
if it's a rental
property, we're not
very too concerned with taxes.
There is no tax benefit
or detriment either way.
Keep in mind, even though
it's an out-of-state property,
and if you formed an
out-of-state LLC, just
by the fact that you're
a California resident
means that you will have to pay
$800 for that out-of-state LLC
here.
So really, the question
is how comfortable are you
with going into partnership with
your sister, the odds of you
guys suing each other?
If you guys are close, the odds
of your sister as your tenant,
suing you, is probably very low.
Yeah, the question is
if you're not really
charging a lot of rent, how
does that work as a rental?
So on the tax side, you do
have to charge her rent.
Otherwise you
don't have a stance
to take as a rental property.
It could be below market
value, because it's
a partial ownership.
That's perfectly fine.
So maybe she pays
you $300 of rent.
But you'll still
get your 1/2 or 2/3
of mortgage interest
and stuff like that.
AUDIENCE: But isn't
that more of a given?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: It can be.
Gift taxes can definitely
come into situations
where family member's involved
and you have transactions
or below market.
So there's definitely
things to think about.
The other thing I
was thinking was
in terms of how you
structure the ownership.
You might want to look at
economically, outside of taxes,
economically look at do you
get a better deal buying it all
yourself, from a mortgage
standpoint or a financing
perspective?
Or maybe it flip flopped.
Maybe your sister does.
So those are other
things, outside taxes,
things to think about
too, just how you actually
buy the property.
AUDIENCE: I was curious if you
do much with family limited
partnerships?
This is something I
read about recently
that was pretty fascinating
for protecting your assets,
as well as shielding
your taxable inheritance.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: Yeah,
family limited partnerships
are very, very popular.
They've been around, tried
and true in the tax world,
in the tax court for decades.
They are very common
with families that
have a large amount of assets.
So we were talking about
the $10 million earlier.
Family limited
partnerships can be
very helpful in those
situations, where you're
trying to-- as Amanda
was mentioning-- kind
of gifting partial ownership
of properties over time,
to your kids.
So that can be a way to start
taking a portion of the asset
out of the parent's estate,
so that they're decreasing
their value of their estate
to maybe try and get it
under the $10 million.
But at the same time, they're
still controlling the asset.
But the kids are
involved in the business.
Because in the
limited partnership,
generally it's four,
five, six family members
are all the partners.
And so that's where
it's used a lot.
There's ways to use it to
shift income to different kids
as well.
So there's a lot
of benefits for it.
But from a big-picture
perspective,
we see it used a lot
with the families that
have $5, $10, $15
million-plus in assets.
AUDIENCE: The asset protection?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: Yeah,
the question was, in terms
of asset protection, can it be
a better vehicle for investing
within the family than an LLC?
I think that's probably more
of a question for an attorney.
And I think it
probably could be.
But theoretically, both
come with "limited liability
protection."
So I'd really have to
defer that to an attorney.
AMANDA HAN: I think practically
speaking, the vast majority
of our clients who own rental
real estate use LLCs rather
than family limited
partnerships, are
older clients who've
been in real estate
for many, many years tend to
use family limited partnerships.
And I think partly because the
nature of the estate planning
component.
And then partly just
because back in the days,
FLPs were much more prevalent.
And now LLCs are typically
more preferred by attorneys
for asset protection.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: And another
thing worth pointing out
is with the limited
partnership, technically,
with every one of them,
you have to have what's
called a general partner.
The general partner
is the person
or the entity that's going
to have unlimited liability
exposure.
So a lot of times, with
the limited partnerships,
you have to create a corporation
to be the general partner,
to hold 1%, 5%, 10%.
Obviously that can be done.
It's not earth shattering.
But it's one other
thing you've got to do.
It's another corporation
you've got to create.
With an LLC, you don't have to
have a general partner, per se.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
It's a newbie question.
Suppose I have a
primary residence.
I stay there for a couple of
years and build some equity.
And then what's
the best strategy?
Compare, say, I sell the house
and get half a million capital
gain free, or I cash
out some of the money
and then you do
house improvements
and get the benefits of
the mortgage tax deduction?
Or compare with use the cash or
the money on rental property,
and I heard I can also get
the deduction on the mortgage
interest.
So compare these
three strategies.
Which one is the most tax
efficient in the longer run?
AMANDA HAN: Well, I think if
your primary home is highly
appreciated, from a
tax perspective, first
and foremost, is to lock in that
$250,000 or $500,000 tax free.
And so you can do that.
Let's say, you sold
your house today.
You've been in
there for a couple
years, two to three years.
Then that's fine.
You can move out, sell
it, get the tax-free gain,
take the cash, and then do
whatever you want with it.
Buy other rental properties,
buy a new primary home.
That's all perfectly fine.
If you feel like that home has
more appreciation potential--
you want to keep it, but you
want to turn it into a rental,
you can do that as well.
We do recommend, though, that
if you move out of your home,
you sell it within three years
of turning it into a rental.
Because you have that
additional three-year grace
period, where you have
that rental income.
And when you go
sell, you still can
tap into that $250,000 or
$500,000 of capital gains.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: So
even though you moved out
three years ago, you still get
to use that primary residence
tax-free exclusion,
even though it's
been a rental property
for the last three years.
So you can even do that.
And then you can tack
on the 1031 exchange
that we talked about earlier.
So you can actually take
your $500,000 tax-free cash
in your pocket,
do a 1031 exchange
on the rest of the property,
buy a replacement investment
property, and then
continue to roll that,
but still get your tax-free
money in your pocket.
So we've had clients use that
multiple times and it works out
really well.
AUDIENCE: Can you do both?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
Yeah, you can do both.
It's awesome.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
So the question
is if I keep the property,
refinance it, use the money
to do home
improvements, to improve
that property, or refinancing,
use that money to go out
and buy an investment property.
And I think from an
accountant's perspective,
it's going to come
down to numbers.
It's like, if you're going
to improve the property,
what's it going to
be worth after it
appreciates and improves?
What do you plan to do with it?
If you do take the money
out and reinvest it,
where are you going to reinvest?
What kind of returns
are you going to get?
We like tapping into
equity and utilizing it.
Because we don't
necessarily want equity
not doing anything for you.
But you got to be smart about
it and make good decisions,
obviously.
AUDIENCE: So in terms
of transferring property
from parents to children,
is leaving it in a trust
until they die by far
the best strategy?
Or are there advantages
to it otherwise?
AMANDA HAN: It depends on
the net worth of the parents.
So if the parents combined net
worth is under $10 million,
then generally speaking,
that would be the case.
Of course there's always going
to be different things that
are non-tax-related
that come into play--
the health of the parents,
will they need long-term care?
Do they have creditors?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
The age of the parents.
AMANDA HAN: But
generally speaking, yes,
under $10 million, it's better
to leave assets in the parent's
name and have the kids inherit.
And that's not just
for real estate.
That's also with
stocks, anything
that appreciates in value.
And the reason for that
is when we pass away,
every person get what's
called a step-up basis.
So regardless of what you bought
the property or your stocks
for, when you die,
the kids-- or whoever
your beneficiaries
are-- will get it
at whatever that day's value is.
AUDIENCE: And there's no
limit to that step up?
AMANDA HAN: There's no
limit to the step up, yeah.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: So I
had a client the other day
who basically asked
the same question.
Their parent was, I
want to say, 75, 76.
And my response was no, I don't
think it makes a lot of sense.
Because your parents are closer
to death than they're not.
He's like, what does that mean?
He's like, my parents
are in good health.
And I say, well, they're 75.
That means they're not 30.
They're not 40.
They're closer to passing away
than they were 30 years ago.
And so their window for passing
away, maybe it's 5 years,
maybe it's 20 years.
But they're still closer
to that than they were.
And so if there's a
lot of gain in there,
it's hard to advise somebody to
give up on that tax-free gain
that you could get 5, 10,
15 years down the road.
AUDIENCE: If we have
a primary residence
and also some buy and
hold rental property,
can you talk about if the AMT
affects what we can deduct?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: So if
I understand the question,
so you've got a
primary residence,
you got a rental
property, and kind of how
that plays in affecting AMT?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well, if our job
makes us fall into AMT
does it change any
tax strategies?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: So
AMT is just an acronym.
It just means
Alternative Minimum Tax.
If you're at a
30,000-foot level,
it's an extra tax that the IRS
put in place about 30 years
ago.
It was actually put in place
so that the wealthy people
of the time could stop using all
these tax loopholes they were
using to avoid paying taxes.
And so they were trying to put
in place a minimum level of tax
that they wanted people to pay.
And so unfortunately for
people who live in California,
it's kind of like a
parallel tax system.
One of the things that's
not deductible for AMT
is state income taxes.
And California and New
York are the two states
that have the highest
state income taxes.
Your highest rate
here is like, 13%.
So generally speaking, if
a taxpayer in California
is making $150,000
to $300,000 a year
and paying a good
chunk in state taxes,
they're probably going
to be an AMT, whether you
have a rental property or not.
And so there's things you can
do for AMT, to plan for it.
But just from a
reality standpoint,
people who live in
California are making
six figures, single
or married, there's
a very high likelihood
you're going
to fall into AMT, whether you
have a rental property or even
a primary residence sometimes.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah,
I mean, I think
we don't see rental real
estate as an adjustment
either for or against AMT.
For all of us here, the biggest
thing that changes that number
is state taxes.
And unfortunately,
there's not much you
can do in terms of state tax,
from your W-2 job, at least.
It's going to be withheld
based on whatever it is.
AUDIENCE: The first one is you
mentioned that we can write off
the cost of, for example,
looking for property to invest,
right?
So is this applicable to
foreign countries also?
Or is it only for USA?
AMANDA HAN: No, it's applicable
to foreign countries as well.
Now, with any kind
of travel cost,
the key thing that you want
to make sure you have in place
is predetermined
business purpose.
So what we mean by
that is if you're
going to fly to
Asia, for example,
you're visiting
family, you happen
to look at some real
estate, that does not
make the trip tax deductible.
Because you were on a trip and
you happened to do real estate.
In order for it
to be deductible,
you have to have documentation
to show that maybe I scheduled
these meetings to meet
with these people,
to look at these properties
before you leave.
And the reason, if you think
of it from the IRS's side,
and say, well, why
did you go to Asia?
Well, I went there because I
had all these business meetings
that I had pre-scheduled.
And so that's the same out of
the country, in the country,
going down to
Southern California.
It's always that same
underlying concept
of what is the
reason I went there?
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
So my second question
is how can we
write off the cost on the time
we spend for rental purpose?
It's not like for
home improvement.
We have receipt
but we don't have
this for the time we spend.
AMANDA HAN: That's a
really good question.
We get that a lot.
Unfortunately, the
answer is not a good one.
So the way that--
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: You know,
you asked the right way,
"How can I?"
But--
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: How can I?
AMANDA HAN: So you can't.
OK, I'll re-answer this.
So you can.
However, you would have to
pick up that same dollar
amount as income.
So that just means,
for example, if you
hired me to do your
house improvements,
you write off what you pay me.
But I pick that up
in taxable income,
because I earn the money.
And so if you wanted
to pay yourself,
you can certainly do that.
We don't recommend
it for anyone at all.
Because you're just
writing off and picking up
income in the same
exact dollar amount.
And I know people would
say, well, I value my time.
Maybe I charge $100 an hour
or $500 an hour to my clients.
But I can't charge myself.
I mean, I can, but
it's just a wash.
So we don't really
factor that as a cost.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
Similar question
we get is I donate 10
hours a month to charity
and I value my time
at $200 an hour.
So I think I should be able
to take a charitable deduction
for that value.
And unfortunately, you can't.
AMANDA HAN: But you can
deduct all the supplies
and travel costs for all
your charitable work.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
Right, right.
AUDIENCE: If you have rental
income property in San
Francisco, and you have tenants
who pay below-market-rate rent,
is the amount that
you would pay them
to move out tax deductible?
AMANDA HAN: Oh, mhm, yes.
Yeah.
So you mean, kind of
like cash for keys?
When you pay them to
have them move out?
Yes, that is definitely
a tax deduction.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah.
Unfortunately, we see that
more often than we'd like.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: So you guys
mentioned that there's not
real difference in tax
benefits between LLC
and just holding
it in your name.
Is that also true if
you're trying to buy
properties with a
50/50 partnership?
AMANDA HAN: Well, so
it depends on what
is the intent for the property?
AUDIENCE: Buy and hold.
AMANDA HAN: If it's
a rental real estate,
it's neutral for tax purposes.
Then the only reason
you would have an LLC
is if you have asset
protection concerns
with that particular partner.
So kind of going back to the
other example, with the sister.
Right?
My sister, she's
not going to sue me.
I'm not going to sue her.
If something were
to happen to me,
we know each other's wishes.
You might not need it.
If it's with another coworker,
or even a more distant family
member or friend, you might
want to have a partnership
if there is an asset protection
concern between the two of you.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
Another thing
I should add to that is one
situation where it might make
a difference is let's
say, you're going
to buy it individually, 50/50.
Legally you're probably
going to own it as what's
called tenants in common.
So for tax purposes, that
means you own 50% of it.
You have to report
50% of the income
and report 50% of the expenses.
Whether or not you actually
collected 50% or not,
maybe she collected 100%.
You still have to report 50%.
Now, so let's take that
to the other situation.
Maybe you want ways to
say, OK, we own it 50/50.
But I'm going to 75% of
the expenses and the losses
for the next five
years, until we sell it.
Then we'll even it
out in the back end.
If you want to be able to
do that, then doing an LLC
would be the way to go,
versus the tenants in common.
Because you wouldn't be able to
do that as tenants in common.
So it kind of depends.
If you're planning to
share things 50/50, other
than the asset protection,
it makes no difference.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMANDA HAN: I mean,
just one little tidbit
to throw out-- legal entities,
I know we talked quite a bit
about that.
Timing is also important.
So for California, the $800
fee is not a pro-rated amount.
Let's say, you felt like,
I do want that asset
protection from my partner,
we're talking about.
So now we're close to September.
Let's say, by the
time you decide
to go into this deal it's
going to be November.
And so if you form an
entity in November,
you're going to pay
$800 for this year.
And then you're going to pay
another $800 come next year.
So you're really only
getting that benefit
for a one-month period.
So timing is also important.
If it's the beginning
of the year,
you're pretty sure this is
going to happen, you know,
I would say, go
ahead and form it.
But right now, you
just want to be
cautious of time frame of how
long you're going that benefit,
before you have to pay
that second round of $800.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
A lot of people
are doing Airbnb for
some of their rentals.
Are there any tax benefits
that people aren't
aware of when they use Airbnb?
AMANDA HAN: Yeah, I love Airbnb.
We're seeing so many
clients do Airbnb.
I mean, we're not doing
Airbnb with our rentals,
but I'm definitely seeing really
good profit on the Airbnb side.
I think the main item to think
about for short-term rentals
like that is that they're
treated differently
for tax purposes,
depending on what
is the average number of days
that your guests are staying.
So if you look at 2016,
the year, on average,
if your guests are staying
longer than seven days--
meaning eight days
or more-- then it's
treated like a regular rental
property, which is great.
Because we get all
the depreciation.
It's rental income.
Now, on the other hand, if the
average is seven days or less,
then it's actually treated
like a hotel business.
Which means it's
ordinary income,
potentially subject to
self-employment taxes, payroll
taxes.
So there definitely is
planning involved if you're
doing short-term rental stuff.
Depending on how
significant the income is,
that might be one of
those rare situations
where we would
recommend a Corporation
for that particular real estate.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
But yeah, again, we're
seeing it as a great
business model.
Because people are
getting better returns
on renting the exact same
property that they used
to rent for a 12-month
period of time to one tenant,
they're renting to 35
different people over the year
and making a lot more money.
And it's not just the properties
that are next to Disneyland.
It's markets you
wouldn't even expect
to be "vacation" markets.
But they're finding
enough demand for it.
So it's really working
out well for most people.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Have
they had the strategies
that have been proven fruitful?
Because I know there's
people who have done it,
but there might be a
lot of work involved,
getting tenants in there,
might be more upkeep?
AMANDA HAN: You know,
I have a client up here
who was targeting more
like the corporate guests.
So he said, that's worked
out well for him, just
from people coming from out
of town to do training here.
So when they're
here, they're here
for a couple weeks at a time,
instead of just a couple days
here and there.
But yeah, we have people
who actually move out
of their primary home.
I have a client in Hollywood.
So he's essentially
moved out of his home
because it was so much
more profitable for him
to rent it out on the Airbnb.
Now he's living in
a rented apartment.
And then his home,
he's renting it out.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: From
Chris-- "My understanding
is that deductible rental losses
phase out at $150,000 of income
if not pursuing real
estate as a career.
Do most wealthy individuals
accept this fact
and wait until the sale of a
property and apply the loss?
Or are there other workarounds
for this limitation?"
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
It's a great question.
So just to kind
of paraphrase it,
we were talking
earlier about when
we have cash-flow
positive properties,
but if we can get
enough expenses
and get a loss on paper
for that rental property?
Well, the IRS will say, yes,
you can deduct that loss
against your other income.
But if your income gets to
be $150,000 or more per year,
that takes away your ability
to deduct that loss this year.
Now, you get to carry
forward the loss.
You don't lose it.
And that's what the
question's referring to.
Do people just wait around
and use it in the year
that they sell the
property down the road?
And that's what some people do.
Another option is
people actually started
reinvesting money to
generating better cash flow
properties that they have
positive income on the tax
return, that they can
utilize their losses
from the other properties
to offset that.
That's one avenue
we've seen people do.
Or become a real
estate professional,
where going forward, that
limitation goes out the window.
Because now you are in
the day-to-day business,
whether it's you, or maybe your
spouse or something like that.
So it's an unfortunate
limitation,
because it's been
in place since 1986,
and the numbers haven't changed.
And it's crazy because
obviously in California, you
can get to that income pretty
quickly for a lot of people.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah.
And you know, the person that
asked the question mentioned,
besides the fact, that you
could do it if you have
real estate as your career.
I think that that's a
little bit misleading.
Because to be a real
estate professional,
it does not mean you have to
become a realtor or broker
or get licensed.
Real estate professional is only
a term used in the tax world.
And that simply
means that you're
spending more time
in real estate
than you are at your jobs.
So now if you guys are
working full time here,
that means 40 hours a week.
So to be a real
estate professional,
you got to be working
41 hours a week.
So yes, that is very hard.
But what if you have
a stay-at-home spouse?
If you had a stay-at-home
spouse and they're just
really watching the kids, doing
household things, then really,
for them to be a real
estate professional,
they only have to spend at
least 750 hours in real estate.
And once they reach that
goal, then collectively,
you guys get to use the
benefits of the rental losses
in this guy's situation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMANDA HAN: The question is
how do you document the time
that you're incurring?
So the IRS doesn't have
a specific requirement.
They don't have a form
or anything like that.
The only thing they require
is a consistent methodology.
Meaning if you use
a notepad, they
want you to use that
notepad for the whole year.
Or if going to be your calendar,
something written in Excel,
it just has to be consistent.
Really, the time tracking
doesn't get sent to anywhere.
For our clients who claim real
estate, we don't look at it.
We don't audit
that kind of stuff.
The only time you will
be required to produce it
is if you were to be
audited by the IRS.
Let's say you were
selected for audit.
And they say, well,
I'm really not sure
if you qualify as real estate.
I want to see your time log.
And what they'll do, is
they'll look at your time log.
It might have hundreds of
entries for the whole year,
right?
And then what they'll
do is they'll go through
and they'll do what's
called sample selection.
They're going to
say, OK you said
you spent two hours at Google,
listening to a real estate tax
talk.
Prove it.
So hopefully you have
something-- an e-mail,
or your coworkers can vouch
for you-- that you were here.
In audits that we've dealt
with, thankfully, the agents
on the IRS's side have
been pretty reasonable,
in that they would
select things that they
think could be proven.
So that would mean you went
to Colorado for a real estate
conference for three days.
OK, you should have something
that showed me you were there
doing the real estate seminar.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
So really you're
trying to keep of
a date, obviously,
a description of what you
do, a description of who
you met with, what you
talked about, obviously
the amount of time you spent.
Those are the most
important aspects of it.
And again, however
you keep of it,
it doesn't matter as
long at it's consistent.
AUDIENCE: What
happens if the wife is
an accountant in a
private family firm which
mainly deals in real estate?
Does that count as real
estate professional?
AMANDA HAN: That's a
really good question.
And the answer is, it depends.
[LAUGHS]
It depends.
So if she has a significant
ownership in the business,
then potentially.
But if she's maybe working
for her parents or something
like that, then
the answer is no.
This example, the
most common times
we see this example is
with a W-2 employee.
Maybe you're working for a
property management company.
You're a W-2.
Does that time count?
And the answer is no, if you
are not a significant owner
of that company.
Yes, if you own that
property management company.
That is your real estate
time, even though you're
managing for other people.
AUDIENCE: For the
self-directed 401Ks, can
you advise what your clients
maybe use as the custodials?
Because sometimes some
of the bigger firms,
like Pensco or whatnot,
charge a lot of fees.
And I see a trend where they
have these IRA check books.
And I'm concerned that could
get me into some legal issues,
because I don't
know all the rules.
AMANDA HAN: So in the
self-directed arena,
if you Google
self-directed, there's
going to be hundreds
of names that pop up.
But yes, I do agree, Pensco is
one of the more reputable ones.
They're larger so the fees
are a little bit higher.
But yeah, the question with
how do you find good CPAs,
I would look through your
network here, bigger pockets.
People will share with
you their experience,
maybe paperwork took too
long or all kinds of stuff.
With respect to
the checkbook IRA,
it's really
convenient for people
who maybe need to write
checks out all the time.
The most common times
we see that is-- I mean,
we don't have a lot of
clients that do that anymore,
but-- back in the
days when people
used to go out and bid
at the trustee sales,
they need to have cash
to buy the property.
So that's where
it comes in handy.
Because Pensco is
not going to give you
a check within the
next five minutes.
So you do want to
have that flexibility.
Now, if you're looking to
use your self-directed money
to do traditional
real estate, like buy
a rental property, or
maybe doing hard money
lending, where you're
lending to other investors,
we recommend against
doing the checkbook IRA,
for the same exact
reason you brought up.
Unless you are someone
very well versed
in the rules of self-directed,
it's very easy for you
to get yourself in trouble.
Because when you use
that, we don't see it.
There's no custodian
that sees it.
So it's just more
open to mishaps.
The other thing
is, Matt and I went
to a self-directed training
a couple years ago,
where one of the
directors from the IRS
was one of the speakers.
And they did say,
that there is going
to be a heavier effort on their
end to audit these checkbook
IRAs for that exact reason.
They know that's a lot
of money, potentially,
they can come after, if you make
a small mistake by accident.
Because with self directed,
like we were saying earlier,
you can invest in almost
anything you want.
But there's a lot of
things that you "can't do,"
even after you get
your investment.
So it's supposed to be a
retirement account where
you kind of let it do its thing,
for lack of a better term.
So there's a lot
of things you've
got to keep your hands off of.
And that's where there's a lot
of abuse right now, I think.
AUDIENCE: So I bought
a property recently.
And I had cash just
that I had saved.
And I wanted to invest outside
of the stock and bonds,
so just diversify.
And then the big
question is, well, you
buy a place for like, in this
case, it was $1.1 million.
And then how much
cash do you put down?
You don't really want to
take too much of a loss,
because we can't write
it off as let's say,
as good income earners.
But then you don't want to
be paying money out of pocket
every month either.
So I just took a ballpark and
said, well, I'll put down 50%.
And I'll get a loan
on the other 50%.
And that would
basically break even.
And I'm just
wondering, I usually
go with the 50/50 strategy.
But what do you
recommend in this case?
Of course now I have a
lot of capital tied up
into one property.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah.
I think it really depends.
I mean, the answer's
going to be different
for every single person.
So for you, the options
would be to put less down
and carry more debt.
So if you did that, instead
of putting 50%, if you put 20%
and you did two
rental properties,
what would be the
return on that?
It's a higher risk because you
have more debt to worry about.
So the risk tolerance
level does come into play.
We were talking about
that earlier at lunch.
And so I think at the end the
day, for me as an investor,
I look at the numbers.
I look at the worst-case
scenario for me.
And I would say, OK, in
the worst-case scenario,
would I be OK?
Would I be able
to carry this debt
on this particular property?
And if that answer is yes,
then I'm comfortable with it.
We have a lot of clients
that are more high risk.
They want to put
the minimum down.
They want to get as many
properties as possible.
Maybe because
they're really young,
they're just starting out.
They feel like this is the
time to take the gamble.
Don't want to wait
until I'm almost
retiring to take that gamble.
So those are the factors
that you're looking at.
I don't think there's a correct
answer to 20% versus 50%.
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean, one
thing I think we all see
here is it's pretty
difficult to buy,
let's say, rental properties
and even break even.
It's just the factors aren't
here, especially in California.
So I know it's kind of
outside of tax advice.
But where do you see your
active real estate investors,
or buy and hold real
estate investors,
where are they buying
now, to make numbers
add up to where you said?
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: We
have a lot of clients
buy throughout the countries.
So we've got a lot of
clients that buy in Texas,
Georgia, Tennessee, Ohio.
AMANDA HAN: Yeah, Ohio.
I mean, I don't know the
market in Ohio at all.
But yes, I have a lot of
people that have cashed out
of California, going into Ohio.
I think that good
and bad is they
take the appreciation
from California,
and they move to Ohio.
There, there's probably not
going to be much appreciation.
but what they're
getting is cash flow.
So that's a personal question.
What's more important to you?
Do you need the cash flow
to live off of right now?
Probably not.
So would you rather
have the appreciation?
Another area that we have
a lot of clients going into
is Florida.
So from what I hear,
our clients that
are full-time active
real estate investors,
it sounds like Florida today
is kind of where California
was maybe two, three years ago.
So people are still
flipping there.
They're still doing wholesale.
Wholesale is almost
impossible to get here.
Because there's no margins.
AUDIENCE: What's wholesale?
AMANDA HAN: Wholesale
is when I get a property
under contract at a good price.
And then maybe I
wholesale it to you.
You buy it and then you
either turn it into a rental
or you're going to
do a fix and flip,
and you're going to rehab it.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND:
And she gets a--
AMANDA HAN: And I
get a wholesale fee.
MATTHEW MACFARLAND: --$5,000
wholesale fee for doing
the transaction, basically.
AMANDA HAN: Kind of
like a finder's fee.
So those kind of deals
only work when there's
a healthy margin in the profit.
That's why we don't really see
a ton of that in California.
But yeah, some of
those other states,
like Matt mentioned, Georgia,
Tennessee, Texas, Florida,
Ohio.
AUDIENCE: For someone
who's always just kind of
bought Turbo Tax and
winged it, can you
talk a little bit about what
a typical interaction is
with a CPA, like, aside
from just filing taxes?
What kind of time
and expense is there
throughout the year, and
planning and strategy,
and stuff like that?
AMANDA HAN: I think
it's going to differ
with every single firm.
For us, our emphasis is on
tax planning side of things.
So we have clients that come to
us for planning and tax return.
Or we have clients that come
to us just for planning.
So like I said earlier, the
planning part-- if you've never
done planning before, if
you've always done it yourself,
I highly recommend you invest
the time and the energy
to do at least one comprehensive
planning so you have a roadmap
to follow on what some of
those high-level items are.
But the reality is
that is going to be
kind of a living document.
Because today you have
these sets of rentals.
Tomorrow you might go
into a multifamily.
And so the strategy
itself will be changing
throughout the years as well.
I think the most effective
planning is really
just open communication,
as easy as that sounds.
Because really, the
goal is not for you
guys to understand everything
there is to know about taxes,
and be updated with all the
various tax changes that
come out during the year.
That's your CPA's job.
But your job, really, is just
to keep them updated on anything
that you think
might be changing.
I might be buying a car.
I might be getting married.
I might be getting a divorce.
Those are times when there
could be a lot of money
at play, shifting of money.
That's the times when they will
be able to help and guide you
on what are some of the
things to keep in mind.
JORDAN THIBODEAU:
Well, thank you
very much for coming through.
AMANDA HAN: Yes.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: You guys
flew from Irvine to join us.
So my final question
is, are you going
to be deducting that expense?
AMANDA HAN: Of course.
[LAUGHS]
So for trips like
this, we basically
don't even leave the house
with our personal car.
We just leave our house
with the business car.
Because everything here is
going to be tax deductible.
JORDAN THIBODEAU: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JORDAN THIBODEAU: I'm
going to send their contact
information out after the talk.
But what we're going
to do real quick
is give them a round of
applause for coming through,
and thank them.
So thank you.
AMANDA HAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]